the next couple who will dance in the
finale is Alexis how are you feeling
right now yeah wonderful
I feel good I feel like this is my best
night yet and I'm so happy to go out on
this night and I couldn't be more proud
and I just feel so happy I mean he's
conquered it and we made it to the
freakin semi-finals are you kidding so
so happy yeah what are you gonna miss
most about this experience and what are
you excited to kind of leave behind
I'm gonna miss Jenna seeing Jenna every
day I know I was telling him like I've
spent more time with him than like my
family and Val within the past two and a
half months so we've gone uh we've
become really good friends it's weird
what are you excited to kind of leave
behind performing oh yeah I don't know
if I had another dance in me that's why
I was you know I was kind of relieved I
mean the bottom three Alexis and Alan
and Juan Pablo and Sheryl I didn't want
to kick either of them out
Juan Pablo enforces going home but you
know I'm glad I'm not here and he's
you're saying anything that you would
have done differently throughout this
process no I wouldn't change anything
I'm very happy with it I was myself the
whole time you know the beginning was
extremely difficult for me and you know
I got better at the end it's all I could
ask for I mean do I think I'm the best
dancer in the competition no do I have
the best smile probably you can admit
that yeah
but I'm there you know I'm very happy
with making it this far you know we
thought we were gonna get eliminated a
week more so it couldn't ask for it to
go better what do you feel like you
learned most about yourself through this
process I think
if you put your mind to it you can
pretty much do anything because I never
ever thought I could ever go out there
and do that just dance I would get
nervous dancing in a nightclub or
wherever so to come out here and do it
in front all these people and like
professional ballroom stuff I'm shocked
you know so I'm very happy with it and
Jenna is an incredible person and she's
an amazing coach and I don't know how
she put up with me because the first day
I sort of got it I could like it was
like okay step to the right step to the
left so that's what we were learning so
you know I'm just happy what's next are
you gonna stay in Los Angeles what are
you in Kendall doing you know what me
and Kendall started a little YouTube
channel I think I'm gonna try to stay I
don't know yet I am going to go home to
Chicago for Thanksgiving I can't wait
for that see my friends are you going
with you I know she's staying with her
family but all we could do what's the
goal of this YouTube channel we just
have fun we do a little cooking we're
gonna do some traveling joking how about
that joke and joking and Kendall now
we're cooking now we can finally do some
traveling what I've wanted to do but you
know the lifestyle Channel
yeah great some restaurants you guys go
will you be back here for the finale
I'm gonna be back next week so we're not
really going anywhere you have to
perform all over again probably probably
a pretty epic surprise for everyone next
week so I mean just know what it is but
I think everyone's gonna want to tune it
watch can you give us a hint you're
gonna be happy
Kendall's gonna be on the dance floor
with you
[Music]
No are you I can't talk your life no
[Music]
[Applause]